Lady gentleman.
Black helicopters have been spotted.
This is the hundredth episode 200 episodes ago,
by the way,
focusing,
and this is our 300th episode.
All right folks,
this is the 401 to the big ones should goddamn loud.
Even though I love Lucy and got 400 fucking,
this is episode 500 could you imagine of life was 3-d.
The stars have aligned.
The prophecy has come true.
Alex Jones and Eddie Bravo together on episode nine one one youth.
It was preposterous.
I don't have that much to say.
People say you repeat shit.
I'm like,
what the fuck do you think,
man?
Come on dude,
it's questions.
Let's see this dash.
How dare you.
Now that you've ruined it,
Michael Shermer,
how dare you?
That's pretty preposterous.
What do you always have to talk about?
It's fucking annoying.
Oh,
you guys ever fucking talk about his week?
You were getting all that,
that stone or we'd,
you weren't getting into space.
We'd on a.com oh,
and it entering the code name,
Rogan,
and you will get 10% off all your orders.
O.
N.
It used a codeword Rogan and save 10% off any and all supplements going to come
to a point in time where there is not going to be any secrets and that's a good
thing.
There's going to be full information disclosed from you to me and,
and what it is is the convergence of all human beings.
It's pretty fucking crazy and that's where it's going.
How come I can bank online?
How come you can deal with the entire world's economy through computers and the
Internet,
but you can't vote.
Really when it should be is it should be no Mexico.
There should be no United States.
There should be no Canada.
They should be the planet earth.
That's really what it should be.
These ideas are fucking stupid,
but the DMT experiencing itself is unbelievably intense,
but there is such a radical difference between eating a steak.
He bought a store and eating the back strap of an axis deer that you had to
sneak up on.
We all love to sleep,
but everyone's afraid to die.
This is a guy named Fritz harbor.
Yeah,
Fritz Harbor.
You know the horrible tragedy of Fritz Harbor.
Dan Carlin's hardcore history Dan Carlin podcast,
where he talked about the Mongols and Dan Carlin thing on,
um,
on the history of the Mongols.
This was when they had the operation Northwoods thing that had been passed.
And if you haven't seen that document,
that's crazy.
That is a direct result of my obsession with quake.
This is all from my quake playing days.
I got addicted to video games because of news radio because the writers,
the writers room where they had a land party.
So that was the next quick too.
I was so obsessed with this that I,
I put a t one line in my house so I had a t one line install a,
you must have been rich.
I was rich,
the sensory deprivation chamber.
It's been the most important tool that I've ever used for,
for mine,
for in my mind.
How much do you fuck with the isolation tag?
I lived in Colorado in the marriage,
lived eight miles down a dirt road.
My dog had eaten by a mountain lion.
I mean,
I lived in,
I talked about this yesterday.
I lived in the mountains of Colorado for four months,
did he?
That's where I wanted to live,
and just last year till my dog had eaten by a mountain lion and my wife got
pregnant or to eating some nice plump dogs along the way,
they do downing months on the,
yeah.
Yeah.
It was like,
man,
I'm sorry man.
Let's change up the topic.
A lot of outlines up there too.
Yeah.
They eat dogs,
dogs and cats.
Let's buy a house in the mountains.
So it was a on the top of a mountain and my dog got eaten by mountain line.
Whoa.
Yeah.
That became a bit in my act.
And if you play in the podcast,
drinking game drink I've seen too in my life and they were both maybe like 60
the first one was probably like 60 pounds in the Senate and get your dog or
something.
Yeah.
That was about 60 pounds.
Okay.
[inaudible].